ah petrol it isn't cheap to understand
its price let's trace it back to its
source crude oil is extracted from a
well on land or at sea and routed to a
refinery where it's processed into
different products the petrol and diesel
fuel then head for the pump what makes
up the price of a liter of petrol the
price of the crude oil accounts for
thirty percent including a small amount
for the biofuels added to the petrol the
price of crude oil depends on a number
of factors supply and demand okay quotas
speculation economic climatic and
geopolitical ups and downs and so on
since global reserves are limited in the
future the price of crude oil is
destined to rise possibly with sharp
fluctuations in addition there are taxes
on average in the European Union excise
duties which is centered a fixed amount
per liter represent forty five percent
of the price of petrol thus an average
of twenty percent for the v80 lastly
some other small elements make up the
remaining five percent of the price
transport of the crude oil which
accounts for point four to two point
five percent of the price of petrol
refining around three percent and
logistic storage and profit margin
making up one percent in Europe the
price of petrol varies because not all
the Member States taxi to the same road
to avoid distortions of competition and
to discourage people from fueling up in
other member states where prices are
lower Europe aims to harmonize the
taxation of petrol but why all these
taxes they're an important source of
revenue for the Member States which try
to shape consumers practices by keeping
prices high for example to encourage
public transport petrol will remain a
costly product and would become very
scarce so let's up for energy efficient
and less polluting vehicles or
alternative means of transport everyone
will come out a winner